types of problems quantum algorithms can
solve how they relate to create
cryptography and and also made me
mention some problems that maybe we can
find quantum algorithms for in the next
5-10 years so find you so I'll start
with problems that that have quantum
algorithms so here we're looking for
exponential speed ups compared to the
best classical algorithm that sorts
which was factoring out of them and the
street log Alvin for the street log and
the related crypto systems they're RSA
and diffie-hellman so after he found
these algorithms in 1994 you know some
of the most obvious questions people
were looking at you know there are
quantum algorithms for lattice problems
that's still an open question graph
isomorphism you know what else can we
find the next exponential feet up
speed-up that we found this rappels
equation so you know here is the in this
equation you're given a positive non
square integer d you want to find
integers X Y such the x squared minus y
equals 1
there were some other associated
problems that were also solved like the
principle ideal problem in the class
group now you know from a quantum
algorithms perspective we're just trying
to like find you know any problem we can
solve but it turned out there was also a
key exchange system the buffoon Williams
key exchange systems that was based on
the hardness of this and part of their
motivation for developing it was in case
there was a classical polynomial time
algorithm for factoring hopefully their
system would still be secure but the
realm of quantum computation it's not
then after a while we found quantum
algorithms for creating the unit group
of a number field and this ended up
having a connection to a special case
lattice problem that I'll talk a little
bit about later and it's related to some
crypto system soliloquy a certain fully
homomorphic encryption scheme and maps
and plus there's some other number
theoretic problems like problems from
function feels like discrete log and the
divisor class group computing Hilbert
class feels of certain types these are
the the problems though you know you
have an input and output you know what's
going
these are all classical input classical
output yes so in order to to get you
know more understanding of corner of any
computational model another way to look
another way to approach it is through
Oracle problems and there are a list of
also Oracle problems that have
exponential speed ups no classical input
just an Oracle that you can query that's
let's started with the recursive for a
sampling problem by Bernstein above
irani which gave the first super
polynomial speed-up of quantum computers
versus the best randomized algorithm and
Simon's problem which is a very
important one also so here you're given
some function on this group Z 2 to the N
to some set and it hides a subgroup in a
certain way and your goal is to compute
this subgroup and you know it's an
Oracle problem and but yes so Peter shor
said he was reading dan Simon's paper
and he saw that this was finding hidden
periodicity
the way I first looked at it but and you
know that was part of his path to
getting to the factoring algorithm was
it's also interesting because I talked
to Dan Simon and I was like I have this
you know we had found a hidden shift
algorithm and I was excited to talk to
them about it but he wasn't super
interested and he's like you know so I
asked him like the end Simon where did
you come up with Simon's algorithm he
said well I was in graduate school and I
really didn't like quantum computing and
I was trying really hard to show that
quantum computers are useless then I
came up with this problem and he showed
an exponential separation so maybe you
can keep that in your toolkit for
algorithm development
okay so then the next problem was the
dividend there's a different type of
problem finding hidden shifts so this
one was first based on the Legendre
symbol chip the Legendre symbol problem
so those are just symbol tells you
whether or not a number as a square mod
p so it's one if it's a square mod P and
minus one otherwise so if you think of
filling in your array of all the
Legendre symbol values you get ones and
minus ones half of each because half the
numbers are squares in this problem
you're given like a cyclically rotated
version of this vector and your goal is
to find the shift so you're given f of X
which is the Legendre symbol of X plus s
polynomial time quantum out and you
solve that this has some relation to
capital and not directly but it's been
suggested to you know for pseudo-random
bits you could pick a random part a
random spot in this array and output
like a Polly length sequence
it's a little bit different because you
don't have access to as much of data
okay so these are sort of two of the
things we look for hidden in general
quantum algorithms when we're trying to
solve problems you could do other hidden
period their cities are there hidden
ships of a certain type this was
extended to work on bent functions and
and they actually it's actually been in
so the algorithm working with bent
functions has been implemented on five
quantum bit computers and also 11 the
sort of benchmark how well there's
machines are working
and then I'll give one one more example
this one is not related to crypto yet
maybe it will be at some point so this
is the glue trees algorithm so here you
have an exponential sized graph and what
you can do is create a vertex and get
the names of the neighbors of the
vertices and the graph has a special
structure so there's a there's a binary
tree on the left and a binary tree on
the right and then you connect the
leaves with a random cycle so we're just
trying it so and then what you're given
the name of the entrance for a text and
you're trying to get to the knee you're
trying to get to the exit vertex so if
you start you can query the entrance and
you get the neighbors and then you can
sort of go along the tree to side up to
the up to the middle and then you a
classical algorithm gets lost in this
cycle there's this quantum algorithm
they found as a random walk where it
starts in the superposition of the
entrance and then second level third
level and it just kind of moves left to
right those open how to find a path last
I heard
then there's some other problems hidden
radius problem problem outside
polynomial hierarchy so these are the
the main exponential speed ups we know
outside of simulating physical systems
quantum mechanical systems the other you
know application area
all right so post quantum cryptography
is we've been we've been doing about
this our goal is to find and use crypto
systems that are secure against quantum
computers talking about finding classic
with you know classical crypto systems
in cryptography what that requires is a
hardness assumption right so decryption
should be hard so we need some problem
that's hard for computers to solve and
we don't have techniques to prove lower
bounds so what you have to do is assume
some problem is hard and we need to
somehow gain confidence that there is no
algorithm for some problem so as I
mentioned some some problems have been
ruled out and then in this NIST call
this NIST standardization process there
are some leading contenders with lattice
problems I Sarge any problems coding
based problems and multivariate
polynomials we figure out which of these
are hard for quantum computers to solve
and I'm just mentioned I'm not going to
talk about it in this talk but another
area for post quantum cryptography is
when you're dealing with photographic
protocols so even if you know even if
you have some cryptographic hardness
assumptions like suppose you'd assume
there's no quantum algorithm for a
lattice problem when you design
cryptographic protocols you need to then
have a security proof for that that
assumes the adversary is quantum and in
general of the proof shows like you know
if you break the protocol then you break
the cryptographic cryptographic hardness
assumption and that requires a separate
proof in addition to the assumption
I want to focus on hardness assumptions
in this talk in this in the
standardization process they're asking
for public key encryption cams and
digital signatures as far as motivation
why are they doing it now they say one
thing is the noticeable progress on
building quantum computers the second
thing is it takes a lot of time to
develop standardized and deploy system
so you need to start early but one thing
if we start with deploying systems you
know it's easy to test new systems right
when you think like ok how hard is it to
replace crypto I think well I like hit
download new browser and then you know
but but you know that's only for testing
new systems what's hard is getting rid
of all of the old stuff so for example
there's National Academies report that
then was talking about they pointed out
that it took 10 years for Microsoft to
get rid of md5 which is broken in 2005
through a software update you have to
make sure that people place what they're
using with something else
and another thing that Dan mentioned was
you know some things you need to stay
encrypted for a long time like national
security documents dull health data
there's a problem if I if I you know if
I'm gonna encrypt my health data today I
wanted to stay encrypted for twenty
years or longer forever basically so I
need to encrypt it today with post
quantum crypto I shouldn't be using RSA
to encrypt it so I already need to know
what the new crypto systems are I should
be using
that's deploying deploying takes a long
time also developing new systems so what
are we going to replace our current
system with that also takes a long time
how do we show systems are secure you
know can't prove lower bounds on
problems so the best we can do is like
try really hard not break it you know or
you know what's common is to show that
breaking a crypto system is related to
some well studied hard Pro hard problem
for example with RSA you know it's
related to factoring integers we know we
can factor we can break RSA and we look
for these functions that are easy in one
in one direction and hard in the other
so for example take two large Prime's P
and Q it's easy to multiply them but
this factoring problem is going from
right to left you start so you know we
have to decide when when every confident
that a that a problem is hard to solve
factoring as we heard you know okay we
heard that about lattices so for
factoring is a similar answer it's been
studied for centuries and no a fast
algorithm has been found like a nice
argument but you know I think we do have
to be careful a little bit and even in
factoring it was kind of the surprise I
think in the late 80s when the number
field sieve was discovered so the the
running time the best classical
algorithm ran in time like something
like 2 to the N to the 1/2 and then the
number field sieve was discovered and it
brought it down to something like 2 to
the N to the 1/3 so it still is an
exponential time algorithm by you know
that changes the key sizes you have to
use by a lot when the exponent goes from
square root n down to Q for them
okay but you know so in in post quantum
we don't we're not gonna use factoring
anyway so where do we look for hard
problems for crypto so you know we start
looking at around NP and I'll blur the
distinction between function problems
and decision problems so we're looking
for something without an efficient
algorithm so we don't care about
polynomial time we can't use those MP
complete would be sort of the first
natural reaction but as far as we know
those are pretty hard to use there's
some evidence with theoretical results
showing that if you could base crypto
and np-complete problems using specific
types of reductions the polynomial
hierarchy collapses and actually what
the in this proposal these multivariate
polynomials are using special cases of
MD complete problems the problem is one
of the problems is NP completeness is a
worst-case notion you're only guaranteed
there's one hard instance for each and
input size cryptography you need to be
able to pick random Keys random
distribution they all have to be hard
and there's a mismatch there so what
ends up happening as we look in this
class sometimes called NP intermediate
where we look for problems that aren't
np-complete aren't polynomial time we
can do so you know starting at the
bottom
factoring discrete log tells equation
other variations of that lattice
problems
I saw Jenny's graph isomorphism encoding
fits fits in there too if we're looking
for heart problems for crypto
classically this picture makes sense but
if we retell the story for quantum now
now we want to figure out you know which
of these problems also do not have
quantum polynomial time algorithms so it
started you know you have to rule out
using factoring and discrete log then
Pels equation
Buchan williams key exchange system and
then finally you know we finally worked
more than ten years and got the unit
group and arbitrary degree and one
interesting thing happened at this point
which is
the special case lattice problems fell
down and there's a link between the unit
group and this and I'll try and tell you
a little more about that
so that would be quantum algorithms and
then after I am done with that I'll tell
you about something where we don't have
any exponential speed ups yet but
somewhere where we may be able to find
exponential speed ups in the next 5-10
years which is misogynist about where
things like the eCos hidden subgroup fit
in this big map it's outside quantum
polynomial time right now it's an Oracle
problem so yeah I don't have Oracle
problems written down on this so I don't
but you would guess it's close to the
curve oh I don't know where it is I know
where it is today I don't know where it
belongs this is yeah this is not like
the final line necessarily right now
it's on the side
maybe it solves a sub piece of some
problem like in itself you know it might
still be useful okay though yes and it's
used there okay there is a sub
exponential time algorithm for I saw
Janine's using hidden shift which is the
dihedral hidden sup your problem and
there are attempts to connect it to
lattices that haven't worked because
it's floating around but it's
okay so um first I'll tell you about
this connection between the unit group
and lattices this general question is
are there other quantum algorithms for
lattice problems and this is still
mostly open first I just want to tell
you that that's not like a single
question it's not just like a quantum
algorithm for a lattice problem there
are actually lots of different types of
lattice problems and also different
types of lattices so the question gets
more complicated so if you haven't seen
a lattice here's an example of a
two-dimensional lattice it's the group
in R to the N the street set of points
it's generated by a basis so you might
be given say two basis vectors V 1 V 2
and the lattice is the set of all
integer linear combinations in a
computational problem the first one
shortest vector problem is given a basis
for the lattice you would like to
compute the shortest vector so one
closest to the origin most shortest
nonzero vector so there's the shortest
vector problem the closest vector
problem there are special cases of these
where the crypto is actually these are
the problems crypto is actually based on
gothis VP and BDD for general pencil
bill ideal problem and then there are
other places lattices are used in not
this sort of way but there are things
were there's a hidden lattice and you
want to find the basis to begin with
instead of the basis being the input the
question is what is a basis for the
lattice sorry for for the classroom for
cyclosporine which is input of the
program
I haven't said
and you think anywhere you would like to
use it so we looked for what I was
talking about finding hidden periodicity
'he's right the answer to that
periodicity is a high dimensional
lattice so in this case I have the
number field case in mind which is what
I'll talk about but all you know I
mainly we just want to say that when you
talk about lattices it's very you know
if you're familiar with you know if you
work with lattices all the time it's
common just to think what about this but
there are other problems where it's
finding the basis of the lattice instead
different problems you also have
different types of lattices so this one
I'm showing you here is an additive
group you can also put more structure on
it and get a multiplicative group on top
of it use geometry from number fields so
you know when you're saying is there an
efficient quantum algorithm for a
lattice problem there are some different
choices
okay so I want to tell you a little bit
of a story about how we were working on
quantum algorithms on the other people
were working on crypto and they sort of
intercepted all right what makes good
cut though so I'm taking these actually
from the nist call so so you'd like a
good theoretical basis for your for your
crypto system so for example breaking
the system should imply solving some
hard problem or should at least be
closely related to a hard problem
factoring or lattices a lattice problem
you won't have efficiency so small key
sizes efficient algorithms for
encryption for decryption for key
generation they also mentioned
flexibility you might want to have
additional functionalities you might
want to have parallelization of the
algorithms this would be there are more
things I left off but where do you get
all of these things so I'll tell you a
little bit about the lattice story so
way back when it was hard to even find a
random class of lattices that were hard
and I figured out how to do that in the
late 90s but it was hard to build crypto
directly on these random instances and
what really changed that was in 2005
with Legos when he showed that so he
defined a new problem learning with
arrazolo a and he showed that if you can
solve w LW e then you can solve worst
case lattice problems and the reason why
this was was good was because it turns
out that help with LW e was much easier
to build crypto on top of this than on
top of lattice problems
and another thing I'll point out is
though you know quantum talked so this
reduction this is my notation for a
reduction and the Q means it's a quantum
reduction so actually the implication is
that if you solve if you break one of
these crypto systems and there's a
quantum algorithm to break a worst-case
lattice problem so this was this is
really nice you know there's this so
just to give you an eye you know sort of
one step of his reduction to show you
where lattices and quantum come together
so this is a picture supposed to be a
superposition over the dual lattice with
gaussians around each point of a certain
radius one over R and you know known for
a long time you know if we could just
compute this superposition the thing you
can do is compute the quantum Fourier
transform and it would then give you a
distribution over the lattice itself
with Gaussian envelope with radius R and
when you measure this superposition
you'll get lattice vectors that are a
length at most R so to get a short
vector over there you need to be able to
control one over R and that's that's
hard and so what Wregget did really nice
is he used the lwe Oracle which you can
think of as being closest vector problem
if you're familiar with that to create
these super positions so the closest
vector problem closest vector problem
Oracle you can do that easily and so he
showed that like one sort of one round
of this would get you down by a factor
of square root two and then you know
then it's more complicated you have to
sample more vectors and then repeat this
process many times to get a shorter
so this established a really nice
theoretical basis or crypto based on
lattices
there's worst average-case reduction
solving learning with the era's implies
solving a lot of problems so the next
thing on the list I showed you before
was efficiency and here there was a
little bit of a problem because the key
size and the time to take were at least
quadratic in the security parameter and
that's slower than people would like the
solution to that was to start using
lattices that were special case lattices
they're more structure that will make
the algorithms faster
okay so here's the the first one with
Riggins just our lattice is over the
integers the next step was by Lou the
chef Sookie packet and reggae where they
took lattices that came from ideals
atomic number fields ideals inside doing
a miniatures so instead of lwe of
something called ring lwe now the
lattices are actually rings and rings so
there's also a multiplication so there's
an addition startups operation and a
multiplication structure on the on the
vectors in order to the end and that
brought the key size down to linear and
the algorithms got more efficient you
could use fast Fourier transforms and so
on that's kind of where things are are
today now I'll switch for a minute and
I'll tell you that sort of separately we
were thinking about just how you compute
the unit group of an overview
that is what I'll just say that they
were working in number fields we were
working in number fields we were looking
for a hidden periodicity in that case
it's a lattice I don't have a picture of
the last we're looking for
there are several lattices that come up
in these algorithms so there's the
lattice we're looking for this is a
lattice that's in the range of the
function to find that hidden periodicity
I'll just tell you it you know you're
working in the ring of integers and
there's a way to stretch the lattice on
the algebraic norm lines that is
periodic question is like how do you use
this how do you implement this how do
you get anything to work so it has the
property that's periodic on the units so
if you're familiar with the hidden
subgroup problem you know you know this
city you need one two one on the period
it satisfies this but the challenge is
to implement all this and get polynomial
time in the degree so for example how do
we how do you even compute this function
e to the T is a doubly exponentially
large number you can't just compute it
and multiply it times oh and a lot went
into this one thing we needed to do was
a new continuous hidden subgroup problem
definition and an algorithm that solves
that in high degree handled nor that
noisy Fourier analysis over there over
there doing that after ten years we we
finally solved it and then something
kind of surprising happened we're in
this in the sequence of more and more
specific lattices there was another
assumption made where instead of just
using ideals they would pick principle
ideals and they would pick principle
ideals with short generators and the
reason they did that is it just gave
more structure and that more structure
made it possible to implement some new
things there was a certain version of
fully homomorphic encryption motivating
maps and and what came out was there was
this paper published by Campbell Shepard
and grows where they you know it's
called soliloquy a cautionary tale well
you know we were building this crypto
system based on high degree number of
fields
and we broke it using a quantum
algorithm so it turned out that this is
sort of one one assumption to many the
pieces that go into that so there's our
unit group algorithm that was extended
to solve the principle I ideal problem
by Jeff and thing along then the missing
piece so this this let you compute some
generator but you're trying to compute
some short generator and the missing
piece was a classical algorithm that
they showed them their paper well that
they said existed in their paper for
solving the bounded distance decoding
problem in the unit lives
I'll just put up a picture showing you
how all these pieces fit together all
right so the ideal the input is an ideal
a short generator alpha so it's
somewhere near the origin that's what
you're trying to find first step is to
compute the unit lattice using the other
than I talked about then you solve the
principle ideal problem so the principle
ideal problem so this is I is a
principle ideal so you get some
generator beta for that ideal you can't
control how long it is and then you use
this last step they pointed out which
it's all bounded distance decoding and
that gets you to a unit and then once
you get a unit you can adjust you can
adjust your generator by the unit
together shorter the putting these
together also gives you a two to the
square root and approximation algorithm
so this is an example classically we
don't have any sub-exponential
approximation algorithms for these
quantum algorithm gets it
so yeah
so this is my story about lattices I
just wanted to tell you that Fogg Rafi
it helps to make assumptions to make
systems more efficient you know the
question is like where's the line when
do you make too many assumptions and you
know it's those a important open
question whether there are quantum
algorithms for these other cases
lattices that's the part that has
quantum algorithms in my talk and now I
was gonna tell you about you know what I
an example of a set of problems that
might have quantum algorithms in the
future that is from I sahjhan II so
we're really switching gears here sorry
one new possibility is to use a
different way than what we've seen say
with discrete log to use elliptic curves
so usually what we're used to this what
I'm used to maybe not everybody in the
room but the hard problem you want to
use for crypto is discrete log on the
elliptic curve so you pick an elliptic
curve it's a group law there these are
good compared to factoring because you
get smaller key sizes and you know but
Shor's algorithm can consult the screen
log on this so that's not helpful so the
new proposal is to use an exponentially
large set of elliptic curves and the
isogen ease between them so when i
sahjhan e is on a map between elliptic
curves it's a homomorphism so far we
don't have any exponential speed ups
like I mentioned before there's a sub
exponential time algorithm but you know
I think this is a good place to look for
potential quantum algorithms
I'm not gonna talk through this whole
slide I don't know the direct comparison
for key size comparison so it's not all
I saw some u8 systems it's there's
there's two families and for all anyway
and for seaside it does apply but
seaside starts with smaller basis so it
then it depends on the security level
but it's still very small the key size
is complicated there's earth there are
several systems so I'm gonna I'm gonna
try and show you that there are several
different problems by like putting up
some pictures and it only applies to a
subset of those so then you have to look
at that subset and decide so for this
slide I just want to say that there's
you know a lot of crypto has been
proposed hash functions key exchange
signature schemes based on ice ogyny
problems there are algorithms for trying
to solve these problems and other
problems using various levels of
assumptions and also some provable
okay I just want to try and give you
some flavor of where what these I saw
any problems look like so you know I
mentioned earlier say with factoring
there's an easy problem and a hard
problem and you know given two integers
you can it's easy to multiply them it's
hard to factor them so what's easy and
hard misogynist way but give you an
elliptic curve what's easy is to compute
say degree two I Sajha knees that are
adjacent to it or compute the degree two
I sahjhan these out of it so what that
means is you can compute sort of
neighboring elliptic curves of a split
certain constraints
so given any elliptic curve you can
compute the neighborhood you can compute
neighbors compute neighbors you know so
you can like walk along a path where
your it amounts to concatenating
massaging your concatenating
homomorphisms so that's what's easy so
the starting point to develop crypto
systems and what's hard is if you're
given just say 2 elliptic curves suppose
you're given Y over there and you're
giving a prime here and you're saying
give me a nice sahjhan e that connects
those two that's that's the the
assumption is it's hard to do that that
would correspond say a degree 2 to the N
I saw Janee would be like taking n steps
from E but there's like an exponential
search tree if you're just doing proof
for us how do you find where he is
related decision problem to like our two
curves I sergeant is it's gonna be not
in general well they are I saw Venus in
that case up into different not any to
ordinary curve size sightedness
but yeah so if you look at the right
subset of approach you can guarantee
that there is one of those things
interesting
but just to make it slightly more
concrete give in to elliptic curves
they'd be described by these with the
curved equations working over in the
field and you're trying to find you can
describe by Sajha knees in different
ways one way is with a it's a rational
map that's why on that curve to f of X Y
G of X Y on the second curve you know
he's like each curve has an abelian
group structure and you're further
preserving that structure Sean I should
have also asked I'm so sorry is the
decedent problem heart also its
equivalent if you put it the length I
mean if you if you're trying to find a
path in a graph with small degrees then
so if you if you can decide whether
there's a path of a particular length
then you can use that to find a path I
see so then we'd use to each other what
is they I'm not gonna say yes because
there are many variations of these
problems we're talking about the right
one in northern all settings so part of
all this work is trying to figure out
which problems reduce to each other and
then it takes some you have to be pretty
careful with even defining the objects
and what their sizes and everything so
fact barring out ya the complexity of
all the variations is I don't know
nobody's written it down I don't know if
it's obvious or if I don't know it sort
of took more initial steps of just what
are the objects how big are they and so
on problems reduced to one another
it's one type okay there are two types
of by sahjhan graphs I put those in the
next slide but I'm just want to give you
an example super circular just to sort
of again try and make it more concrete
so as I was telling you you can compute
the neighbors of a graph about sort of a
curve and if you imagine just doing that
forever you know you can construct a
graph and LX ogyny graph so the vertices
are super singular elliptic curves up
tight so morphism and then the edges are
so if you're talking about the Li
sahjhan e graph you connect them when
there is a misogynist degree L you do
that the degree of each of vertex is L
plus 1 your graph it's exponentially
large in this case the like P over 12
vertices and given a vertex so given any
vertex in the graph you can efficiently
compute its neighbors
in this case and the super singular case
this graph is also an expander random
vertices by just taking a random walk in
the graph and so you may also use so one
thing you'll see is the term path
finding so this problem of finding our
sahjhan ease is the same as path finding
given two vertices in this graph find a
path between them just the same as
finding a nice ogyny although there are
special cases you can specify like how
long the path is allowed to be and
things like that okay so as I mentioned
there are two types so I just was
talking about the super singular case
where the graph is an expander the
second case is called
ordinary this ordinary is the case where
there's a sub exponential time quantum
algorithm for finding our sahjhan ease
here the structure is different it's
called a volcano looks a little
different so well this is an expander
the one thing to keep in mind is just
like there's a really big cycle and the
suit in the ordinary case so the
structure is different and there's a
group action in the ordinary case that
you don't have up here that lets you
sort of walk around that walk around
these vertices and act on them and that
group action is what was used to find
this to set up a hidden shift problem to
find the ice arginusae between Ian's
crime
now as with the latest case the people
are interested in making these systems
more efficient I mentioned that there
are lots of crypto systems being built
on these hardness assumptions so one
thing you might is want is more
efficiency that's in the ordinary case
but you also want the group action and
so there's a proposal called CS idh
where and that's on this in the super
singular case you can work everything is
over FFP squared if you restrict your
curves down to just FP instead of FP
squared you get a group action the graph
changes somehow and now you also get the
group action on on this this new graph
so everything gets more efficient it's
nice but you know from from an se a
quantum algorithm is first effective or
even classical algorithms the question
is like is it secure once you're adding
more structure is that somehow that
applies to all of these
so Dan was talking about how secures a
lot of space to cryptography we don't
know how these hell secures I saw Jenny
based cryptography to tell you no too
early to know against quantum or even
classical algorithms you know so our
goal some of us our goal is to try and
find quantum algorithms for these Asajj
any problems look on the map you know
it's like you are here it's like we're
sort of way back at the beginning
they're just trying to understand
like I said understand the objects in
the algorithm is it classical algorithms
for working with these and it gets
complicated because III sahjhan ease for
example have many different number
theoretic descriptions you can describe
them as a subgroup of the elliptic curve
as an ideal this rational map that I
showed you I talked about before some of
these are algebraic sum of these are
geometric there's really a lot of
objects flying around to work with some
of the computational challenges that
come up elliptic curves it can be
defined over a small field but all the
tools you're using to work with them
like torsion groups the eye sahjhan ease
themselves are defined over the
algebraic closure and so you have to be
careful that your coefficients of all
these objects aren't blowin up becoming
exponential size for example or your
algorithms won't run an expert in
polynomial time
if you do start looking at this you'll
see there are three basic hardness
assumptions related to this there's the
first one which is computing I saw
Chinese that I mentioned there's one
called computing endomorphism rings
these are AI sahjhan ease back to the
same one so this amounts of like
computing cycles in that graph so you
think it's kind of related to finding
paths you're finding cycles computing
maximal orders so I'm just gonna give a
give one example here a place where just
try to give you a simple example where
structure can help the underlying number
theory can help solving a problem so one
of these print problems I mentioned was
finding cycles in these graphs this is
an important subletting takes
exponential time and the generic way to
do it is just to sort of sample random
paths until you get a collision and if
you you know you pick a path and you
keep sampling paths eventually you'll
have a collision by the birthday paradox
it takes square root there are P
vertices so it's square root P number of
house you take and then you can catenate
your two paths and you get a cycle so
this requires square root P time and
square root P space if you just ignore
the number theory other than using the
fact that it's an expander
but we use some more underlying
structure turns out we can reduce the
space requirement down the polynomial so
there's an observation if you find what
are called conjugate pairs that are
connected by a nice ogyny you sort of
you get a cycle out of that
automatically so we've proved that the
fraction of curves that are adjacent to
their conjugate pairs is one over square
root of P so if we can sort of get any
of these vertices in this 1 over p
fraction of the whole graph we can get a
get a cycle so there we just sample and
now we don't have to keep track of our
paths to use the birthday paradox you
just need one path that gets in there if
we get them as we go and so here again
the algorithm is just you know take
random walks to get a random vertex in
the graph and then you form this cycle
that's still square root P time that
down to log P space it's a classical
classical
okay so just to summarize my talk you
know quantum algorithms and classical
and post quantum cryptography is sort of
intimately tied together some people are
trying to develop post-colonial crypto
some of us are trying to just Oh any
problems we can with quantum algorithms
and you you know this gives us a place
to sort of go back and forth with
developing systems breaking them maybe
with a quantum algorithm it's an
important back and forth we definitely
need quantum algorithms to know how
secure these systems are first of all
we'd like to determine which problems
are secure in theory like there's no
polynomial time quantum algorithm as far
as we know then we have to understand it
more concretely to choose key sizes so
you want to use the best exponential
time algorithms you have choose key size
for those in general these problems that
you know NP intermediate in general but
also these ones that come from some of
the crypto systems with lattices I
sahjhan ease coding theory all the
variations in there that provides a rich
set of problems that we can use to try
and develop new techniques for quantum
algorithms we can start by looking for
hidden periodicity and hidden shifts but
you know maybe among all these things we
also find something else we can do with
quantum computing
stop there Thanks it's about something
which may be a little off the wall maybe
two decades ago there's a lot of
interest in physical one-way functions
using physical systems for example
scattering a light off of paper to
generate a one-way function in the sense
that it's very unlikely that you'd get
the same scattering function with
another sheet of any other sheet of
paper and it was interesting because
they utilize mechanisms to make
cryptographic primitives that may or may
not be quantum secure I'm curious if you
know where this is gone or if are they
is it actually quantum crypto classical
crypto but somehow based on all light
scattering and process in a physical
system in papers or the last five years
your syllabi for escorting collaborators
on what are called quantum readout puffs
so puff is a physically uncodable
function which has illustrated by the
way you're saying then quantum readout
puff is while you fire a superposition
over to somebody's glass which is
optically scattering the superposition I
mean you need to have your superposition
of laser for instance or something that
could interact with the device and then
it sends back the speckles at the
superposition of speckle pattern
switching then meet in some random faces
and then the point is that the the
device unless I mean you could imagine
if somebody could like clones just
devised by like observing how its
reacting to differ
angles different positions of a laser
and then they could build a quantum
computer which could like lead the
lasers that you're firing at it do the
same computation without measuring yet
send back the same results you could
imagine how somebody could clone it but
it of course it would be building a
super expensive quantum device that
anyway there's been various papers which
are actually it does seem to achieve
some security properties which are they
continue just to be clear this system it
is a token yeah this is like a vacation
or it's a key storage you still need
public key cryptography that Sean is
talking awful yes but it would give you
digital signature schemes no no a
signature is something that anybody can
verify like your sir bidding a software
we a signature know that you have all
optic in the library or something so it
would be a weird if you just want
signatures isn't it known how to do that
based on any one way function so it
doesn't need yeah so this I mean that
the situation for quantum secure
signature schemes should be you know
like you want you know more solid even
than that for for public key crypto well
I would actually suggest adding that to
your target list but even though I mean
it's easy to say oh sure one way
functions are easy to build and
therefore we're good on signatures
actually it would be good for people to
look at the proposed one-way functions
the hash functions that people have
written down and say are there any ways
to improve the attacks with quantum
algorithms or just with regular
algorithms various people looking at
that but I think there's not enough
quantum expertise looking at these these
targets
other questions at some point you said
something on lines of we might be five
to ten years away from quantum
algorithms to solve in such a nice I
mean I mean it might be true for every
primitive but why did you pick Asajj and
specifically I know so little about it
that I'm confident we'll find something
to do with this which might be good
lunchtime discussion fodder which is
these are classically in classical out
with classical keys and Daniel
punishment and I played around with
quantum keys for a little bit for our
quantum digital signature scheme but I
haven't seen much follow up along that
direction do you think it's still
interesting to think about quantum keys
for example yeah I mean it's not
something
again I just wanted to remind everyone
that so we resume at 2:00 and there's a
talk and so